i'm sick of good-looking people
beautiful people gorgeous people i'm
done with you men and women yeah i want
to date with this girl when she was so
pretty beautiful but she had nothing to
say she was boring she had no
personality and i checked out at one
point and she goes look i can tell you
don't like me just want to sleep with me
i was like yeah but that's your fault
and she was like [ __ ] you a mortgage a
pretty face i'm like but that's all you
worked on
hours on your hair makeup outfit get a
[ __ ] knock knock joke together
i don't get these googling people they
spend 100 of their time on their looks
zero on their personality you just
assume that part's amazing why would you
have to work on that too give it 80 20
80 20. go to the gym all day put makeup
on then watch half a documentary
i know i'm not a hot guy before it did
i'm writing jokes in my hand limerick's
anecdotes i'm bringing it baby i'm tap
dancing out there you know
like if a girl tells me mark you're
funny but you're not that hot i'd be
like i know that's why i'm funny
[Music]